it's Michelle the muffin behind lab
muffin beauty science and today we're
going to be talking about SPF. SPF is a
phrase you'll hear thrown around a lot
when talking about sunscreens but what
exactly does it mean? Let's break it down
SPF stands for Sun Protection factor.
It's a number that you'll find on the
label of every officially sold sunscreen
usually on the front in really big font
How do they come up with this number?
SPF testing is done on actual human
volunteers in a laboratory. Two
milligrams of sunscreen per square
centimeter of skin is applied on to the
volunteers. A UV lamp is shone onto
Bare skin and sunscreened skin and the times
required for redness or erythema are
measured, and then fed into this formula.
You divide how long it took for the skin
to go red with the sunscreen by how long
it took for the skin to go red without
the sunscreen and the number you get is
the SPF. MED stands for the minimal
erythema dose in other words how much UV
was required for the skin to turn red.
For example if a volunteer normally gets
burned in five minutes under the lamp
with bare skin, a sunscreen that stops
them from burning for 75 minutes or 15
times longer would be classified as SPF
15.
So SPF tells you how many more times UV
your skin can handle before burning with
the sunscreen on compared to bare skin.
So SPF tells you how much longer you can
stay in the sun with the sunscreen on...
doesn't it? Well no. This is a really
common misconception. While the length of
time before going red
is used in SPF testing with UV lamps, it
doesn't work this way in the real world.
The UV lamps used in testing put out a
consistent amount of UV so it's
proportional to time but in the real
world the intensity of the UV radiation
from the Sun that causes sunburn, known
as erythemal UV, changes a lot throughout
the day. In Sydney during summer here's
what the UV levels look like. This is a
graph of the UV index which shows you
the levels of erythermal UV. The higher
the UV index the more erythemal UV there
is. At midday the UV level is 11.9
which is over ten times the level
at 7:00 a.m. which is 0.9 so if your
bare skin normally gets burned after 20
minutes in the Sun at 7 a.m., at midday
you'd only last 22.7 minutes even with
SPF 15 sunscreen on, not 15 times 20
which is 300 minutes or 5 hours. That's a
massive difference. Even with SPF 50
sunscreen you'd only last 75 minutes at
midday. Most of the time it will be even
more complicated than this: clouds absorb
UV and some parts of reflective surfaces
like snow and water can actually double
your UV exposure.
Here's another complication the SPF of
your sunscreen depends on the amount of
sunscreen you apply. As I mentioned
before the SPF of the sunscreen is
measured at two milligrams per square
centimeter on skin. Now 2 milligrams per
square centimeter doesn't sound like
that much but a square centimeter is
pretty small.
Most people use much less sunscreen than
this. Even when they're told to apply a
lot it translates to about 35 mL for
an adult human body which is around a
shot glass full. Most people end up
applying between a quarter and a half of
this recommended amount.
According to a physical relationship
called the Beer-Lambert law, protection
should decrease exponentially with less
sunscreen so applying half the amount of
sunscreen would give you less than half
the amount of protection. But luckily
skin is a bit weird so microscopically
it's quite bumpy and the relationship
that most studies have found is close to
linear. This means that using half of the
recommended amount of sunscreen would
actually give you about a third or a
half of the labeled protection. There's a
common myth that says SPF 15 blocks 93%
of UV, SPF 30 blocks around 97% and SPF
50 blocks 98%, so SPF 50 would only give
5% more protection than SPF 15 and only
1% more protection than SPF 30. However
this isn't a good interpretation for a
number of reasons. Firstly these
percentages are only if you apply the
full amount of sunscreen: two milligrams
per square centimeter and as I mentioned
earlier most people don't. Secondly it's
more important to think about the UV
that does pass through the sunscreen and
gets to your skin rather than the UV
that doesn't pass through. So a better
way of looking at this: assuming that you
apply the recommended amount is that SPF
15 lets in 7% of UV SPF 30 less than 3%
and SPF 50 lets in 2%. So this
means SPF 15 lets in almost four times
as much UV as SPF 50. Here's an analogy:
you earn an average Australians income
$85000 a year. In
other words you don't earn 99.99999% of Australia's GDP 99.99999%
of Australia's GDP does not
enter your bank account. Your boss tells
you that an extra 1% of Australia's GDP
will enter your bank account if you work
an extra hour a week.
You say no because it's only 1%. You then
go off do some calculations and then
kick yourself because it's 17,000
million dollars which would make your
income 20 million percent higher. A
recent study found that SPF 100 plus
sunscreen did in fact in practice
protect more than SPF 50 sunscreen from
sunburns.
So yes going higher with SPF isn't going
to be unnoticeable. In this study 199
people were told to apply two sunscreens,
one on each side of their face. They
didn't know which sunscreen was higher
SPF. After around six hours in thesun
scientists looked at how red the
people's faces were. More than half the
people were more sunburnt on the SPF 50+ side while only 5% of people were
more sunburnt on the SPF 100+ side.
There's been a few other studies as well
that have had similar results. The
problem with going too high with SPF
is that high SPF generally means more
sunscreen actives, which usually means
more greasy and more expensive products.
This might mean you won't end up
applying quite as much of that product
as you would with a lower protection
product, and so you'd end up with around
the same amount of protection. So I would
recommend going with the highest SPF
sunscreen that you can considering your
budget and the formula. There's also the
fact that with higher SPF
some people end up applying less
sunscreen or reapplying sunscreen less
often because they think they're more
protected but you still need to reapply
high SPF sunscreen regularly, because the
sunscreen film will wear off and wear
down over time.
As well as SPF
there's also UVAPF which is protection
from the longer wavelengths of UV that
don't cause burning. But they still cause
skin damage and in particular this is
aging and pigmentation. UVA is also tends
to penetrate more deeply into the skin.
To ensure protection against UVA
you can either look for a numerical PPD
or PA rating which works a lot like SPF.
You can also look for the words broad
spectrum or the UVA logo on your
sunscreen which means that the UVA
protection factor is at least one third
of the labeled SPF. In some countries
like Australia
if the sunscreen has a certain SPF it's
mandatory to be also broad-spectrum. It's
important to remember that sunscreen
isn't the only type of sun protection
and it isn't even the most effective
type of sun protection. You should be
avoiding sun exposure as much as
possible and also using different types
of protection like hats clothes and
sunglasses. These end up being more
effective than sunscreen because you
can't under apply them they won't wear
off and you don't need to remember to
reapply them. If you want to learn more
about sunscreen I have a few other
videos about sunscreen I talk about
how much you need to apply, how to fit
sunscreen into a routine and what the
difference is between chemical and
physical sunscreen ingredients. The links
are in the description or you can just
check out the rest of the videos on my
channel. That's all from me today! If you
enjoyed this video about sunscreens and
SPF I'd love it if you could subscribe
to my channel and like this video. If you
want to learn more about beauty science
you can also look at my blog which has
tons and tons of stuff on the science
behind beauty products. You can also
follow me on Facebook and Instagram
where I post regular tips. See you next
time for more beauty and science!